que patrick klugman des sms de droit des
affaires à dauphine diplômés du cap a ce
qu'il faut pour y être avocat 1 et
président de l'union des étudiants juifs
de france fait à peu près quinze mille
étudiants ainsi l'association
assez assez importante et votre votre
syndicat publie aux éditions de la
martinière le sionisme expliquer à nos
potes avec des textes de alexandre adler
elie barnavi bernard henri lévy jacques
tarnero vous et d'autres
[Musique]
alors le sionisme expliquer à nos potes
donc vous allez nous expliquer un
entrepôt tu leur mets que des potes dans
lequel on est une bande de potes vous
expliquer brièvement et simplement ce
qu'est le sionisme le sionisme d'abord
c'est le droit du peuple juif à
retourner sur sa patrie ancestrale est
devenu un état qui est attentatoire à
temps à temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a hélas
opéré
on sait que paraître jeudi
et bien ça y est tu monde est calme et
pour une fois ça vous concerne pas mon
cher qu'une manne
c'était acteurs directs comme quoi tu
vois on s'attend s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît bien donc c'était acteurs on
sait pas très bien pourquoi enfin bon il
ya de la peinture partout et ça
ressemble à du sang ça devient chaud je
faire de la télé maintenant alors
patrick donc comme je le disais on entre
potes et vous voulez dans la voir
vraiment l'illustration expliqué
expliqué expliquez-nous ce qu'est le
sionisme donc le sionisme c'est le droit
des juifs à retourner à fonder un état
sur une partie de leurs terres
ancestrales qui est la palestine
mandataire est donc cette idéologie a
réussi c'est un des seuls isme qu'a
réussi oui alors vous vous êtes à la
fois sioniste dont vous pensez bien
évidemment que les juifs en droit comme
tous les autres à avoir un état ce qui
est normal même temps vous êtes pro
palestiniens c'est donc ce qui vous
différencie de beaucoup
oui je crois en fait c'est l'évidence
quand on est sioniste aujourd'hui c'est
à dire quoi qu'on attachés à l'état
d'israël à sa sécurité et être attachés
à la sécurité d'état d'israël c'est
aussi vouloir un état pour les
palestiniens parce qu'après tout bon
tant qu'israël n'aura pas de frontières
reconnues la palestine n'aura pas de
frontières reconnues et vice versa et je
crois qu'en fait c'est l'évidence
aujourd'hui les sionistes devrait être
pro palestiniens et pro palestiniens
devraient être sioniste c'est un peu
naïf mais en fin de compte on y arrivera
parce que ça aussi c'est la solution que
le bon sens commande tout à fait alors
comme bernard lévy vous êtes favorable à
a2 et a donc un état israël et à côté la
palestine une espèce de séparation
franches comme ça y est comme il dit une
paix c'est quoi oui c'est une p sèche
pour le moment parce que je crois que là
il ya une situation d'urgence et
l'urgence commande la séparation d'abord
mais vous savez il restera quand même
plus d'un million d'arabes en israël
citoyens et d'une façon les deux
économies sont tellement imbriquées
de toute façon la séparation
l'étanchéité n'est pas possible ni
souhaitable
et après on peut rêver comme shimon
pérès au nouveau moyen-orient une
confédération des états unis du
moyen-orient et c est pour le moment il
ya urgence et d'urgence et la séparation
et ces deux états alors cette politique
est tout à fait acceptable mais que
deviennent les colonies d'israël en
cisjordanie à ce moment là je crois que
s'il faut faire un état aux palestiniens
et bien ça voudra dire à un moment donné
le démantèlement d'un certain nombre
d'entre elles marie lévy dit dans le
texte que vous reproduisez dans le
bouquin il dit qu'il est pour le
démantèlement des implantations non
contigu à israël ça veut dire que les
implantations qui sont sur la frontière
israélienne seront maintenus je crois
qu'il ya c'est des questions qui sont
très compliquées est ce que vous savez
reims par exemple qu'il ya une frontière
et huy dông et d'un côté les israéliens
ce que d'autres c'est finalement bien
sûr mais quand on regarde ça s'est un
peu en taches de léopard dont 6 avec un
tracé à 5km à gauche ou à droite on peut
faire entrer des villages arabes du côté
palestinien et des villages juifs du
côté israélien faudra le faire je crois
qu'il faudra sous cette frontière
tellement compliqué beaucoup de
créativité et beaucoup de conviction
pour le faire vous vous êtes sioniste il
ya des gens qui sont antisionistes il ya
des juifs même qu'ils sont antisionistes
qui pensent que c'est pas bien que tous
les juifs se retrouvent en israël qui
sont pour la pour la diaspora donc
puisqu'il veut dire qu'on peut être
antisioniste sans être antisémite et
pourquoi est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
assimile toujours antisioniste
antisémite
les juifs sont très très nerveux sur ces
questions là subjectivement aujourd'hui
à peu près la moitié de la population
juive mondiale vit en israël où la shoah
va pas revenir sur cette épreuve est
juste après israël et pour les juifs
dans notre vécu c'est le tombeau et la
résurrection et beaucoup pensent refusé
israël s'est refusé quelques par les
juifs vivant par ailleurs aussi il faut
bien le dire refuser le sionisme c'est
refuser aux juifs ce qu'on réclame pour
les autres j'ai d'accord qu'on peut être
antisioniste sans être obligatoirement
antisémite
oui mais enfin c'est quand même
aujourd'hui prendre acte que l'état
d'israël existe
moi vous savez si c'est pour construire
un état pour les palestiniens je suis là
je sais pour détruire l'état d'israël
qui existent merci
non parce qu'elle une soirée au début de
la semaine une soirée organisée par la
licra et vous donc c'était la signature
d'un appel qui s'appelle pour une paix
républicaine il ya beaucoup d'hommes
politiques avaient beaucoup de gens très
importants et le texte qu'on a demandé
de signer précisé l'engagement à
combattre l'antisémitisme ça c'est
normal et toute idéologie qui lui sert
de masque y compris l'antisionisme oui
je crois qu'à un moment bas les masques
ça veut pas dire que tout ancien isme
est antisémite ça veut dire que quand on
se sert de l'antisionisme là que les
gendarmes à garder c'est à dire que les
gens étaient là ce soir là il y avait
tous les ministres premier ministre etc
en effet le fait qu'ils ont signés dont
qu'il soit signé un papier comme quoi il
s'interdisait d'être anti sioniste pas
du tout pas si c'est ce qui nous embête
je connais tête j'ai écrit à combattre
l'antisémitisme et toutes idéologies qui
lui sert de masque y compris lentilles
sur wii c'est à dire que contre
l'antisémitisme s'expriment à travers
l'antisionisme il faudra le combat bien
se raidir combat tout accord or il ya
une enquête dans le figaro qui est sorti
cette semaine j'imagine que ça ne vous a
pas échappé une enquête csa figaro qui
démontre que le sentiment antisémite
recul dans la population et
qu'aujourd'hui il n'est plus que de 9%
oui mais vous n'aurez pas manqué de
remarquer que chez les jeunes il
progresse et ça c'est la première fois
d'habitude les jeunes sont
traditionnellement moins pour eux
racisme que leurs aînés et là ça
progresse 14% 14 pour signer 18,30
s'arrête et vous remarqué aussi que ça
progresse notamment chez des jeunes qui
se disent de gauche
tu veux dire quoi ces excuses il faut
pas en tirer de grandes théories mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on efface
l'antisémitisme se diffuse quand même il
ya un soft qui va si tu veux dire que
rien ne protège de rien moi je crois que
est jeune ça protège pas de la bêtise
bien au contraire être juif ça protège
pas du racisme
être de gauche non plus et aujourd'hui
on peut pas être l'anti racisme c'est
une valeur de gauche ou de droite je
crois qu'il faut être simplement
vigilant c'est une attitude citoyenne
avant tout qui n'est ni de gauche ni de
droite c'est un seul fondateur et c'est
ça enfin je lis quand on fait un sondage
le figaro donne les résultats et 87% des
français qui ont
problème avec les juifs en france voilà
où est le problème
où est le problème déjà la france n'est
pas un pays antisémite énorme que ça
serait déshonorer la france que de dire
mais en revanche quand on révèle
l'antisémitisme qui se passe de grave on
rend service et honneur cette démocratie
à la république
vous savez il ya quand même selon un
rapport de la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme près
des deux tiers des actes racistes en
france vise la communauté juive tir
présent que je vous rappelle moins d'un
pour cent la population française quand
des gamins sont obligés de changer
d'école ou parce qu'ils sont juifs c'est
très grave
cette haine on l'a prise dans nos écoles
et si on regarde ça comme des tensions
inter communautaires on regarde ça comme
des indigènes qui se battent entre eux
et c'est vrai que dans les cours de
récré il ya une tribalisation c'est vrai
que le il se consacre plus que comme
fuck beurre blacks mais sont des petits
français et j'en ai parlé avec le
ministre de l'éducation et 10 faut
donner au beurre une image positive
d'eux-mêmes leur parler d'un
verrouillage monsieur le ministre faut
leur parler eux et à nous de victor hugo
et à tout le monde et c'est là dessus
qu'on y arrivera c'est l'école qui nous
rendent encore moins raciste d'un sur un
autre article dans le temps autre
article dans le figaro cette semaine
donc la guerre d'irak apparaît à
beaucoup de gens comme la guerre des
juifs
c'est très choquant c'est très choquant
pourquoi
sans entrer dans un jeu politique passe
évidemment cette thèse ne tient pas
debout
ça veut dire quoi la guerre des juifs ça
veut dire que ça profite à quelque chose
de culte et vous savez quand on dit la
guerre d'irak s'est avéré juifs on n'est
pas loin de la thèse du complot il est
une chaîne comme ça qui est infernale et
vous dire moi j'aurais bien aimé aller
manifester contre la guerre en irak je
les fais au tout début et puis très vu
très vite j'ai vu qu'il s'agissait
d'autre chose
j'ai vu que en tant que juif j'étais
interdite de manifestation contre la
guerre
j'étais pas souhaité et ont quelque part
on nous a volé notre débat on nous a
interdit la dans la rue d'être des
français comme les autres dans les
cortèges très moi j'ai un copain il
s'appelle know i'm no m lévy s'est pris
un coup de barre de fer ils traversaient
ça les gens sont ils un cortège s'est
formé autour de lui on me dit c'est
injuste un juif et ils se succèderont
notamment parce que des religions
d'aider des gens de religions
différentes et d'ethnies différentes
sont venus manifester contre cette
guerre
ces gars heureusement que c'est surtout
les français qui ont manifesté contre
cette guerre et les français c'est pas
que les musulmans
quand on est juste malheureusement dans
ce truc là quand vous voyez les les
fameux drapeau les toits de jean égale
égale la croix gammée quand on a vu tout
ça dans des manifs anti guerre quand on
a vu le progressisme au bras quelque
part d'islamistes avait quelque chose de
très malsain dans ce cortège et je peux
vous dire qu'on en était physiquement
interdite et c'est quand même dommage
alors on va terminer par quelques
réflexions sur ce qui s'est passé dans
cette émission
par exemple gad elmaleh vous avez pensé
quoi quand il a il est venu dans cette
émission un moment il ya eu un pugilat
entre le créateur de mecca cola toufik
mathlouthi et william goldnadel qui est
avocat qui est vice-président de france
israël à un moment ils se sont opposés
et gad elmaleh n'a pas voulu défendre
israël celui été amèrement reproché moi
j'ai entendu des radios communautaires
juives le dimanche lendemain où il a été
extrêmement critique et vous pensez que
c'est normal ça qu'on lui qu'on oblige à
prendre position s'il n'a pas envie de
prendre position
moi ce que j'ai lu de gad elmaleh il
regrettait d'avoir pris position qui s'y
retrouvent un peu désarmée sur le
plateau et voilà mais par contre ce que
j'ai entendu dans la communauté
ça existe et sur cadel malawi non
c'était très choquant moi j'aime pas
vous savez les campagnes ad hominem
oui parce que lui il vient ici pour
vendre un film s'il n'a pas envie de de
s'impliquer mais je voulais surtout à la
base et encore une fois je reproduis ici
les propos de gad elmaleh il voulait pas
entendre ce qu'il a entendu il voulait
pas assister à ça bon maintenant il y
assister moi c'est sûr j'entends ce que
mathlouthi a dit ça n'aurait pas pu et
je leur ai dit mais bon gad elmaleh
oui c'est vrai qu'il a sa liberté
d'artiste c'est vrai que beaucoup de
gens se sont sentis blessés
vous savez
il ya quand même un sentiment
d'inquiétude qui traversent des justes
de france en ce moment et que quand il
ya quelqu'un qui est issu de cette
communauté
eh bien on a envie qui porte une parole
moi je crois quand même que à la fin
chacun est libre de sa parole est bon
toute façon gad elmaleh il regrette ça
ils regrettent pas avoir pris position
mais en tout cas il faut pas que les
gens soient obligés par contre c'est
vrai et puisqu'on en parle ce qui a été
dit sur ce bateau à ce moment là était
très grave et mathlouthi est quelqu'un
de profondément aimé le spectacle
moi je vous dis j'étais très mal à
l'aise en regardant l'émission c'était
mal à l'aise parce que ça donnait ses
deux combats de chiens entre le juif et
l'arabe
on attend des problèmes c'est soit on
les gens se rencontrent ici c'est un des
derniers endroits à la télévision
française où on peut discuter
il y en a plus donc soit ils se
rencontrent et discutent soit on fait
venir les juifs puis quand ils sont
partis ont fait venir les venir les
musulmans ça va être très compliqué donc
à un moment bien que les gens puissent
parler entre eux c'est quand même ça
qu'il faut rendre et je suis là ce soir
merci moi mon but en tout cas parler
modestement fait de rendre la parole aux
modérés pas de prendre les extrêmes 1
mon but c'est à rassembler les gens
alors jacques tarnero dans ce bouquin
parle aussi de tout le monde en parle
qui décidément on fait beaucoup parler
il parle de l'altercation qui a eu entre
besancenot donc la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire avec q kerman donc et le
patron du crif
deux ans nos wii s'est fait traiter
d'antisémite ça lui a mis les larmes aux
yeux je vois pas en quoi c'est
répréhensible sa non les larmes
oui bon c'est l'idée c'est quand même un
leader politique les larmes c'est un
argument c'est facile ça s'appelait je
n'aime pas utiliser les larmes
je crois que c'est pas digne surtout
quand on est un leader politique moi je
crois que il avait raison s'il n'est pas
antisémite de se sentir à dean et moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est que voilà si s'il
est pas antisémite
ben faut y croire et s'il l'est pas faut
qu'il fasse attention dans ses rangs et
dans ce qu'il s'exprime à ses côtés
c'est tout et puis voilà bien parce que
je voulais rappeler simplement moi pour
finir c'est qu'ici on reçoit des
chrétiens des juifs des musulmans des
bouddhistes des athées et des
agnostiques avant tout d'ailleurs des
citoyens de la république française
parce qu'on est tout citoyen de la
république française quel que soit notre
notre religion et que tout le monde en
parle ça veut dire aussi tout le monde
peut en parler
donc je continuerai à recevoir ici
toutes sortes de gens que je ne serai
pas monotone
une piscine par les contours
en tous les cas c'est très bien ça
explique beaucoup de choses merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ça
s'appelle le sionisme expliquer à nos
potes merci et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux